you've written 35 books 35 books right
many of them most of them about Hank
zipser yes Hank sister is a child with
dyslexia
oh my yes and and you you have dyslexia
well and these are books that you wanted
to write for oh I didn't want to it
happened by chance a man named Alan
Berger said to me write children's books
about your learning challenges and when
you grow up with a learning challenge
you think you're stupid so I said I
can't write a book so he said I'm going
to introduce you to Lyn Oliver who knew
everything about children's literature
and together we have written 28 novels
about Hank and on October 1st a brand
new novel a new character a aliens
superstar a 13 year old alien lands with
his spaceship on the backlot of
Universal Studios and he gets a job I
don't know how this happened on a sitcom
as an alien yeah that's a great idea
thank you yeah and so these books you
must encounter I've been told you
encounter a lot of people who say those
books meant a lot to my kid yes those
books really help my kid identify and
made me feel a little better about their
situation and have more that is true
outside of my family mmm-hmm my proudest
moment no matter what I have achieved
are the books right I did not think I
could write one
[Applause]
Henry News Henry's new book alien
superstar is going to be available
October 1st yes and I think that's a
vanilla doing thank you yeah I use
everything you're doing and it's funny
they're comedies first
all right well check them out yeah I
mean you I want you to look I'm going to
okay the author you should most
difficult things I'm going to read the
book on tape you know so that I and it
is the most difficult thing for me to do
is to read out loud because I miss words
I I can't pronounce words that I even
know no one would believe that that was
true because of all the success you've
had and you're such an incredible
former and it seems to come so easily to
you no one watching this right now would
ever think that Henry Winkler had that
problem ya know or I had that issue or
had that struggle but there are so many
children who you know one out of five
children have some sort of learning
challenge and in this country we do not
look at them and say you are fabulous
the way you are and that you will become
something wonderful something
magnificent I have met doctors and
lawyers and plasterers and plumbers and
actors dancers all who I have dyslexia
it is just we learn differently but we
are incredibly wonderful in our minds
yeah yeah and have so much to offer
that's great that's great
make sure you look at these books as
they said Henry's new book alien
superstar will be available October 1st
and Q facin good good luck to you at the
Emmys really I'm so happy for you yeah
he's good man
[Applause]